hey everybody it's Mike from order flows
and welcome to today's video now today
is Friday uh December 23rd you know
we're coming into the Christmas weekend
you know I know a lot of Traders have
already uh taken off I believe Europe
was already closed
um you know Central Europe was closed
for the trading day and again coming
into the day session you know you should
have already well I mean coming into the
day you know that the Market's going to
be a bit quiet and you know overnight
fairly fairly tight range you know we
opened up at 38.50 had a low of 37 and a
quarter a high of 59 and a quarter so
right in the middle of that coming into
the morning session you know we did get
a little bit of range expansion
um you know at 7 30 to the downside and
then back up to the highs and then when
cash opened up we pushed lower we made a
new low and then we rallied back up just
recently you know I'm shooting this
video around uh three in the afternoon
and you know around two o'clock we just
made that new high and you know we're
trading up around that high right now
but you know what I want to talk about
is you know what to look for in the
order flow on slow moving days again you
know you know it's the Christmas
holidays coming up you know
um you know
Central you might say Central Europe but
Europe is pretty much uh already closed
down for the holidays
um you know so you should be expecting
quiet trade and when you have quiet
trade it's there's not much really to go
off of on the order flow oftentimes
because you don't you're missing a lot
of participants and one of the things
that I learned quite early on with order
flow I'm talking you know over 10 years
ago is
you got to be looking for what the
aggressor or what the aggressive Traders
are doing in the market and the easiest
way to determine that is you know
through imbalances as well as the Delta
and so what I'm going to focus on today
is the Delta
specifically the Delta surge now the
Delta surge is a way to read the Delta I
do have an indicator on my website so if
you're using ninjatrader 8 you can
download it from there I've seen other
people copy it
um you know they use the same name
um but you know they're sort of missing
out how to use it in context right
they're just sort of taking a you know
the sequence of Delta and applying it
everywhere well you should there's
there's a little bit of nuance to it
okay and you know with anything with
order flow right you got to take it in
context of Market structure not just
take every time there's a you know a
buying surge or a selling search and
basically all a surge is you know it's
really simple
um
what you have is you know you got the
one bar here that's positive Delta
you're looking at the Delta then it's
negative more negative more negative now
there's a little bit more to it because
I've seen people basically just sort of
take that and anytime you have you know
three
negative Deltas that are growing or
three positive Deltas that are growing
in a row
calling it a surge when it's really not
there's a relationship between the way
that the surge grows and you know it's
unfortunate you know everyone thinks
that they're gonna take my idea and you
know and start saying I've seen people
take these you know the Surge and
they're selling it in their software
it's like you know why it's free all you
gotta do it honestly is just whether you
use a ninja Trader or not
um you know if using Sierra charge
emotive wave whatever for your footprint
you just watch the Delta and this is
what you're going to look for right
you're going to look for the positive
Delta then the negative more negative
more negative but you know you you want
to see some expansion because if this
just goes from minus 152 to minus 163
you know to minus 170. yeah technically
you know Delta is growing stronger but
it's basically flat okay so you know you
want to be watching how the growth is
going between it and then you also want
to take into account Market structure
where you are in relationship to the
high of the day the low of the day the
swing High the swing low or even the
open
right as you're going to see here
because you know what on slow days
markets tend to rotate around the open
and
when they're rotating around the open
you're not getting any directional move
so don't expect much to happen right
because you know if you're trading
around the opening price later in the
day you know it will be opens at five in
the afternoon and then by you know 10 30
you're still trading at that price Mark
is probably not going to make much of a
move right you're really what you want
to be trading is after a market has had
a move
and then you're starting to get that
turn right because that's where your
Edge is going to come in is you know
when the market is turning you know as
you can position yourself you know when
that market is making that turn to take
advantage of that move so for example
right cash opened up today here at what
was it 8 30 right we went up and then we
sold off into new lows and you know new
low new low rallied up about uh you know
about 20 points right it doesn't look
like a much of a move but over three
minutes we went from 24 and a quarter
all the way up to 45 right then we
started selling off
so we got the positive Delta here and
then negative 152 negative 220 negative
281 and again the market sold off
basically from 32 all the way you know
very quickly down to 25 26 then sort of
went sideways before we made this new
load down to 21 but you know
realistically your move that you could
have caught is somewhere between 32 and
25 26 right so that's like what seven
point move
um okay then you know we started seeing
some more you know fluctuation you know
right at nine o'clock I made some data
come out and then
um
this line right here 3850 this is the
opening price right now there's an
indicator on ninja
Trader that's a free indicator on
ninjatrader it's got nothing to do with
my software you just open up your your
charts you scroll through your
indicators you find it here it's called
current day open high low I like to use
that because it gives me reference of
where we're trading relative to the high
the low and more importantly where we
open and you know people say well this
isn't the previous days closed more
important well honestly you know we only
close for an hour and generally we're
going to open right around where we
close anyway
um you know it's I I treat the opening
price just as important as the previous
days close because oftentimes it's right
around the same level
okay so
um where am I here okay so 3850 is the
open and you know still keeping an eye
on Delta okay so if you're just again
looking at sort of the raw numbers in
Delta so you got this positive Delta now
again remember 3850 is the open and then
minus 168 minus 179 minus 6.99 and this
is where a lot of the people that are
trying to copy the Delta surge in their
in their tools sort of make this mistake
because they just see well it went from
negative 168 to negative 179 so it grew
and then minus 6.99 this isn't enough
growth right minus 168 to minus 179
right it's only 11 contracts and and
that's not enough right that's the
difference of one trade you know this
you know in the e-minis 20 Lots go
through that no problem right so again
it's the difference of just basically
one trade
I I would basically treat these as equal
I wouldn't consider this necessarily a
surge right in this market now if I'm
talking something like
um soybean meal or oil you know or you
know some of these smaller contracts you
know that might be enough but definitely
not in the e-minis so it's not just
about taking seeing well it went from
168 to 179 to 699 I have a surgery I get
short no all right and last thing you
want to be doing also is trading it back
into the opening range or the opening
price rather because you know that
that's where it can often stall out
right because the market has no
direction right now it's 9 30 in the
morning
and we're still basically trading at
unchanged or you know at the opening
price
but again you know this expansion isn't
really a surge because you know the
difference between 168 to 179 is
minuscule
um okay so then you know again a little
bit later
uh you have another surge coming in here
you can see it right 381.
then minus 209 minus 311 minus 584. okay
you're getting that expansion you know
it's over a hundred contracts difference
between the 209 to minus 311 then from
the minus 311 to minus five it's real
expansion it's not an expansion of 10
contracts or 11 contracts it's a hundred
the only problem I don't like about this
is it's just right at the opening price
again 38.50
and it just sort of hangs around there
for one bar two bars three bars before
it you know has a little bit of a break
but again even though it has a break how
much of a break is it because
realistically
even if you were to get short in here
you know worst case scenario you're
getting short at 47 and a you know was
that 47 and a quarter it only breaks
down to 42. you know he just sort of
just hangs around here that's the
problem when you're trading around the
opening price yeah it can make a move
down but it's probably gonna be a small
move it's not gonna be much of a move
then again
similar thing
24 minus 35 minus 144 minus 400. again
you're right at the opening price that's
what we talk about you know when you're
you understand where you're trading real
in relation to
the opening price which is more or less
the previous day's closing price or the
higher or the low
right you don't want to be trying to get
a trade-off going you know in an area
where the market is pretty much balanced
right right smack dab in the middle of
value area because again you know if
you're getting short here what's your
potential well we know we just broke
here only about four or five points and
just sort of went sideways and came
right back up to that area that area
rotating around
um where am I here so that was yeah
there was one here
um let me see here I think there was
another one sort of coming in here
again you got the positive Delta 158
then minus 79 that's good some expansion
minus 236 79 to 236 there's a decent by
150 contracts then minus 269 so
technically while this is a surge
right 79 negative 70 you know the
positive the negative 79 negative 236
negative 269. this isn't enough
it's 30 contracts
right
it should be something not say
legitimate but you know something decent
right because you're looking for more
aggressive selling coming in and yeah
while you do you have more aggressive
selling at minus 269 than minus 236 but
it's not really enough
right I have my own certain thresholds
that I have programmed into the Delta
surge I even let you adjust them but
you know it should be over a certain
amount rather than just you know because
technically if this was minus 79 minus
80 minus 81 all these other copycats
would would have that as a surge when
it's really not really a surge right
it's not increasing and again you're
trading it right into
the opening price they're not expecting
a move there
right and you can see it just sort of
hangs around in here hangs around
and then
um you know later in the day
or yeah around lunch time I think we're
coming in here again there's not really
any surge surges taking place here
yeah and again you know this is sort of
one of the the things that I've seen
some versions of the surge are missing
out they'll just take well here I got
three bars and it's gone from two to 44
to 112. oh that's a surge yeah but it's
in the middle of an area where you
already got positive Delta you want to
be changing from you you'd have to have
negative Delta then the positive more
positive more positive
okay it's just not just any three bars
of increasing Delta
and here 1235 they got you can see it
here right so you got the negative Delta
positive six so minus 15 to 6.
okay honestly six isn't very much
you know usually with s PS I have a
minimum requirement with Delta to
actually take it as a reading which is
50 otherwise you know it's just kind of
neutral but anyway we'll just look at
the numbers here 6 143 241 so you are
getting some decent expansion you know
from 6 to 143 the 143 to 241.
were well enough from this 3850 this one
just didn't work out right no you didn't
trade any higher coming in here right
after this 241 you don't even take out
the high of the previous bar at 38.66.
all right so you can even though you're
using the search it's not like something
you're going to be blindly buying or
selling you still want to see that price
action
so if it's not there there's absolutely
no reason to take the trade even if you
took the trade okay fine you just you
should be stopped out pretty quick
um you know Market eventually started
falling down then again you're getting a
decent surge here so it's positive
39 then minus 86 minus 124 minus 192.
people say well you know that that's not
much it's difference of 40 contracts
here about and difference of about 50
contracts here
again at this point we're not trading
thousands of contracts in a bar this is
only 860. this is a thousand and forty
this is 13.78.
and the change in Delta is about what is
that 40 it's close to about 50 percent
increase here
and in here
um you know 124 to 192 what is that
about I don't know 30 I want to do the
math in my head but um it's at least
over 30 percent increase so it's decent
it's not like a five percent or ten
percent
and then you this one had the nice
sell-off again you know it's coming into
this area
you know 38 59 you know this bar proved
it right really quick all the way down
to 50 you know one and three quarters
then sort of trade it back up
but this is the type of move that you're
looking for I do know I got this open
here 38.50 we're well enough away that I
could get short into it we're about 10
points away
but again I need a quick uh seven point
move
in a minute
all right so
you know when you're looking at the
Delta you still got to put it in context
of the market you still got to follow
with what's the follow-up order flow
afterwards right I've explained this uh
in my video yesterday about the letting
the market get you into the trade right
I have the Delta setting up here you
just drop in the cell stop in in this
bar
all right because you can see the Delta
already giving you the sign after
through this bar this bar this bar so
you're coming in here you're just
looking for that confirmation and a
strong negative Delta and then you just
drop in your your cell stop right in
here at 59.
and then boom bottom falls out in the
next bar
before coming back up okay that's the
whole concept of the surge it's not just
oh I've got
positive more positive more positive
you gotta let the market take you in all
right you gotta let the market continue
showing you that bullish order flow if
you're not seeing it then this move's
not going to happen
right and then you still got to take
into context of what where we're trading
right if I'm shorting this Surge from 59
I'm not looking to move
to get all the way through 50 all the
way down to you know the low 40s because
I know that this is the opening price if
we're going to trade back around it
we're probably going to rotate just as
we did earlier on those other surges
right again you know even though these
are surges it's not surges I want to be
trading because we're trading in the
middle of
you know a value right basically
right in here
okay so again you know understand Market
context you still you use an order flow
order flow is just a tool
right it's not an indicator by itself
but it's a tool that you want to be
using together with Market structure
Market context price action
so it's just something to enhance your
trading so again you know I hope you
enjoyed this video
and you know have a great holiday if I
don't get any videos up between now and
Christmas I'll try to but again you'll
be sure to like And subscribe the
channel right because that's what keeps
me coming back
and making more videos for you guys so
let's thanks everyone have a great uh
holiday bye-bye